hilfe nach brandkatastrophe von moria
union und spd streiten wie viele
flüchtlinge nach deutschland kommen
dürfen
gemeinsame sache in sotschi wladimir
putin empfängt präsident lukaschenko aus
belarus und sagt ihm umfangreiche hilfe
zu und tränen bei deutschlands bestem
tennisspieler alexanders wäre verliert
das finale der us open in fünf
dramatischen sätzen gegen den
österreicher dominik team
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und herzlich
willkommen norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport ein junior von mir
wie viele flüchtlinge von der
griechischen insel lesbos soll
deutschland aufnehmen
vielmehr fordert die spd und stellt der
union ein ultimatum
die kanzlerin will bis mittwoch
entscheiden ihr sprecher kündigt einen
substanziellen beitrag deutschlands an
betont allerdings es handele sich um
eine einmalige notsituation durch das
feuer im flüchtlingslager moria wurden
letzte woche etwa 12.000 menschen
obdachlos
einige leben mittlerweile in
provisorischen unterkünften die aufnahme
von bis zu 150 unbegleiteten
minderjährigen hat innenminister
seehofer schon zugesagt über das ringen
der regierung berichtet andreas ruppert
das flüchtlingslager moria besser gesagt
das was davon noch übrig ist geblieben
das unermessliche leid der menschen in
den 2400 kilometer entfernten berlin
sind die flüchtlinge zum zankapfel in
der regierungskoalition geworden die spd
macht druck will mehr menschen aufnehmen
gestern im zdf stellt die
parteivorsitzende cdu und csu quasi ein
ultimatum
wir haben tatsächlich den wunsch dass
wir morgen gemeinsam eine entscheidung
treffen
das eps bisherige blockade eines eigenen
deutschen anteils und voranschreiten es
aufgegeben hat heute allerdings klingt
das ganze schon weniger scharf wir
wollen unbedingt erreichen dass jetzt
schnell eine klärung herbeigeführt wird
48 stunden sind glaube ich ein ganz
guter maßstab angesichts der drängenden
herausforderungen eine europäische
lösung soll her
angela merkel so ist zu hören sei dazu
in enger abstimmung mit innenminister
seehofer den hat die spd als haupt
blockierer bei der aufnahme der moria
flüchtlinge ausgemacht zuspruch für den
innenminister gibt von der
schwesterpartei
also was seehofer den wieder
vollumfänglich unterstützen der ist in
guten gesprächen es geht darum die
europäische lösung zu kriegen es geht
darum sich abzustimmen
der wird heute und morgen darüber
gesprochen und dann sehen wir weiter
der brauch ist jetzt eine koalition
länder die bereits sind menschenleben zu
retten und damit auch die ehre der eu zu
retten
europäische ehre hin oder her für die
afg sollen die flüchtlinge bleiben wo
sie sind hilfe an griechenland aber auch
ein entwicklungspolitisches konzept den
menschen vor ort helfen und nicht durch
eine unsinnige ungesteuerte
einwanderungspolitik auf lesbos bauen
sie im eiltempo am neuen
flüchtlingslager 12.000 menschen die
jetzt obdachlos sind sollen dort dann
untergebracht werden konnte lapentti in
berlin die spd drängt darauf mehr
flüchtlinge aus moria aufzunehmen wie
könnte eine lösung aussehen mit der alle
ihr gesicht wahren
also eine lösung scheint sich zumindest
anzubauen allerdings noch nicht heute
denn so sehr will sich die cdu dann doch
nicht unter druck setzen lassen die
heute hier auch getagt hat dass das
ultimatum was die spd parteivorsitzende
da gesetzt hat das wird auf jeden fall
gerissen
die cdu hat auch noch viel
diskussionsbedarf denn es gibt in der
partei zwei lager die einen sagen
grundsätzlich wir sollten unserem eine
europäische lösung bemühen und
befürchtet einen sogenannten pool faktor
das heißt weitere flüchtlingsbewegungen
wenn man menschen nach deutschland holt
aus griechenland die an das andere lager
sagt angesichts der bilder in moria
dieser erschütternden bilder muss man
jetzt handeln muss man jetzt helfen da
da kann man keinen aufschub mehr
hinnehmen
und diese beiden lager müssen sich jetzt
eben irgendwie verständigen in welche
richtung das gehen kann das sieht man an
den aussagen heute der generalsekretär
paul signac schon gesagt eine einmalige
kraftanstrengung ist wohl nur ist wohl
nötig und möglich und wir haben es auch
von norbert röttgen gehört der gesagt
hat lasst uns doch 5000 menschen
aufnehmen
der entwicklungsminister gerd müller hat
2000 vorgeschlagen irgendwo dazwischen
kann sich das alles natürlich bewegen
damit könnte die spd sicherlich auch
leben die rede von einer vierstelligen
zahl
das ganze soll bis mittwoch entschieden
werden dankeschön noch berlin schock
unter labbadia weiteres großes thema in
der hauptstadt die kommunalwahl in
nordrhein-westfalen mit 14 millionen
wahlberechtigten die größte wahl in
diesem jahr in deutschland und das
ergebnis halt nach die cdu bleibt mit
34,3 prozent stärkste kraft die spd
rutscht ab auf 24
3 die grünen im höhenflug klettern um
8,3 punkte auf 20
die fdp 5,6 die linke 3,8 und die fdp
verdoppelt ihr ergebnis auf 5 prozent
die reaktionen aus der hauptstadt hat
nicole diekmann die kommunalwahl in
nordrhein-westfalen natürlich auch thema
in berlin
adenauer haus am morgen ankunft armin
laschet im gepäck das historisch
schlechteste ergebnis der nrw cdu bei
einer kommunalwahl doch er zeigt sich
zufrieden ist man doch weiter stärkste
kraft das zeigt natürlich dass der kurs
der mitte den wir in nordrhein-westfalen
in den städten und im land immer
gepflegt haben dass der sich bewährt und
dass man so auch wahlen gewinnen kann
insofern war das ein schöner tag
er ist ein erfolg der die vor ort
gekämpft haben und er gibt rückenwind
für den kurs der mitte auf rückenwind
hofft er nun auch für seine ambitionen
auf den cdu vorsitz als nachfolger von
annegret kramp karrenbauer auch das
wahlergebnis der spd historisch schlecht
der absturz massiver als der der cdu
auch hier versucht man sich das ergebnis
schönzureden spd ist klar zweitstärkste
kraft
das haben vor einigen wochen noch nicht
viele für möglich gehalten und bei der
europawahl der letzten wahl der großen
wall vor anderthalb jahren war die spd
drittstärkste kraft in nordrhein
westfalen
insofern ist das schon eine erkennbare
trendwende stärkste kraft in köln bonn
und anderen großstädten die grünen haben
gestern abgeräumt und legen den finger
in die wunde der spd wir reden hier
schließlich nicht über irgendein
bundesland sondern das
bevölkerungsstärkste bundesland der
bundesrepublik deutschland und vor allen
dingen über die ehemalige herzkammer der
sozialdemokratie und eine sehr sehr gute
startrampe für die nächsten zwölf monate
berlin am tag nach der kommunalwahl in
nrw warmlaufen für superwahljahr 2021
die cdu wollte sich eigentlich drei tage
für ihren parteitag nehmen jetzt müssen
wegen corona wenige stunden reichen am
vierten dezember in stuttgart um den
nachfolger von parteichefin kramp
karrenbauer zu wählen weitere
grundsatzbeschlüsse wie die einführung
einer frauenquote müssten verschoben
werden sagt generalsekretär zickzack
eigentlich sollte es ein großer
eu-china-gipfel in leipzig werden doch
wegen corona gab es stattdessen heute
nur eine video konferenz in kleinen die
konflikte mit china sind immens aber es
steht auch viel auf dem spiel
2009/10 handelten beide seiten jeden tag
mit waren im wert von durchschnittlich
1,5 milliarden euro für die eu ist china
der zweitwichtigste handelspartner nach
den usa für china ist die eu sogar der
wichtigste
gunnar krüger berichtet sei wie shell
grou jinping europa und china schauen ob
sie noch mehr verbindet als eine
datenleitung europa muss ein spieler
sein kein spielfeld so tönt europas
klassensprecher unter deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft hätte man sich
vorher eng abgestimmt ich glaube das war
schon allein für uns alle ein sehr
wichtiger prozess der auch ein beitrag
dazu ist dass wir eine außenpolitik in
zukunft machen können
für strategische partnerschaften die
mehr aus einem guss ist ich sage nicht
schon dass es schon so ist so bauen in
kroatien etwa die chinesen schnell und
seltsam günstig eine staatsfirma erhielt
wohl hilfen aus peking genießt aber
freien marktzugang europa ein spielfeld
kein spieler und umgekehrt wir würden es
begrüßen wenn wir ein
investitionsschutzabkommen bekommen
müssen aber auch festhalten dass wir
seit sechs jahren verhandeln und die
chinesen sich überhaupt nicht bewegen
carl martin welcker baut maschinen die
prothesen bauen er verkauft sie nach
china und es dort ohne konkurrenz
so soll es bleiben technologietransfer
ausgeschlossen
wir haben für viele viele jahre den
chinesen eine art welpenschutz bewerb
diese zeit ist vorbei china ist
erwachsen
diese stimmung stärkt ihnen den rücken
beim thema menschenrechte europas trio
sprach an dass sheen pink nicht gern
hört ich kann dazu nur sagen dass der
präsident aus seiner perspektive
argumentiert hat das sind sicherlich zum
teil unterschiedliche argumente als die
die wir benutzen die eu sieht china noch
als partner und als rivalen und wird
sich bald entscheiden müssen
eine gute nachricht aus der berliner
charité den kreml-kritiker alexej
nawalny geht es zunehmend besser
seit drei wochen über der 44-jährige in
der hauptstadt behandelt
auch französische und schwedische
speziallabor haben jetzt bestätigt dass
man wahlen mit dem nervengift novy job
vergiftet wurde
andreas kinder ist das ist eine neue
härte reform von naughty dog war die
alexej nawalny vergiftet hat hat zuerst
das institut für toxikologie der
bundeswehr in münchen ermittelt aber
auch andere speziallabor entnahmen
proben
die bundesregierung teilt heute mit dass
neben den münchnern auch wissenschaftler
in frankreich und schweden das
nervengift festgestellt haben eine
weitere probe wurde der organisation für
das verbot chemischer waffen in den haag
übergeben
deshalb möchte ich noch einmal sagen
dass wir nicht weiter erwarten dass der
überbringer der schlechten nachricht
nämlich wie angegriffen werden sondern
man sich mit der nachricht selber
auseinandersetzen sollte aber die gegen
vorwürfe aus moskau werden heftiger
außenminister lavrov der seinen
deutschen amtskollegen zuletzt vor einem
monat getroffen hat behauptet einen für
morgen geplanten besuch in berlin
abgesagt zu haben aber berlin hatte gar
keinen angekündigt diplomatische
eskalation
wenn es den fall wollen die nicht gäbe
würde der westen einem anderen vorwand
für neue sanktionen finden im fall
navalny haben unsere westlichen kollegen
alle vernünftigen grenzen und die
grenzen des anstands überschritten
ein chemischer kampfstoff vergiftet
einen politiker und zerstört die basis
des deutsch-russischen verhältnisses bei
den regionalwahlen in russland hat der
kreml weitgehend seine machtfülle
verteidigt aber auch die opposition
konnte erfolge erzielen und zwar in
sibirien in den stadträten tomsk und
nowosibirsk setzten unterstützer von
alexei navalny ihre kandidaten durch so
verlor in tomsk die kriminal partei
einiges russland ihre mehrheit in der
ratsversammlung
russlands präsident putin ist genau wie
der belarussische präsident lukaschenko
seit vielen jahren an der macht beide
kennen sich gut und so wundert es nicht
dass lukaschenko in der krise putins
unterstützung sucht heute in sotchi es
ist lukaschenko es erste auslandsreise
seit der umstrittenen präsidentenwahl
gegen die jede woche hunderttausende auf
die straße gehen für begabt zur
rückendeckung aus dem kamin roter
teppich keine blaskapelle als
ranghöchster im begrüßungskomitee der
gouverneur von krasnodar
es gibt keine zweifel wer hier der
kleine bruder ist alexander lukaschenko
zu besuch bei wladimir putin in sotschi
dafür verlässt der präsident belarus
inmitten der innenpolitischen krise sie
haben sich sehr ehrenvoll und anständig
verhalten deswegen möchte ich ihnen
persönlich danken so wie all den russen
die ich nicht extra auf zählen die
bereit sind uns zu unterstützen in
dieser nachwahl zeit in minsk sind die
sorgen groß was das treffen der
präsidenten für belarus bedeuten könnte
ich habe angst dass wir einen großen
teil der unabhängigkeit unseres landes
verlieren
wir befürchten dass dokumente
unterzeichnet werden die man nur ungern
in belarus sehen würde
wir befürchten eine expansion russlands
das wollen wir nicht unterschrieben
wurde in sotschi nichts aber zusagen
gemacht ein kredit in höhe von 1,2
milliarden euro für belarus neben
politischer unterstützung aus moskau
mit jeder dieser hilfen wächst die
belarussische abhängigkeit von russland
russland steht zu all seinen
verpflichtungen auch zu denen die im
rahmen der vereinbarungen über einen
unionsstaat getroffen wurden
wir betrachten belarus als unseren
engsten verbündeten
die rhetorische umarmung seines älteren
bruders wie lukaschenko putin nennt sie
könnte das belarussische volk weiter
gegen seinen machthaber aufbringen
zur corona lage da meldet die
weltgesundheitsorganisation einen neuen
höchststand an neuinfektionen weltweit
knapp 300 8000 neue fälle so viele wie
nie binnen eines tages in deutschland
haben sich im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage täglich 1430 menschen neu
angesteckt gestern waren es 1390 die
zahl der neuinfektionen zeigt dabei nur
einen ausschnitt weitere wichtige zahlen
und analysen haben wir in der zdf-
heute- app darunter auch die frage warum
in deutschland bayern am stärksten von
corona betroffen ist die whu rechnet
damit dass im oktober und november die
zahl der korona toten in europa steigen
wird
trotz der sorge vor ansteckung dürften
in italien heute millionen von schülern
erstmals zurück in ihre klassenzimmer
über sechs monate lang waren sie corona
bedingt nicht mehr in der schule
ausruhen annette hilsenbeck ein stück
normalität ist zurückgekehrt in italien
seit märz hatten die schüler zu hause
online und
echt jetzt sitzen sie wieder im
klassenzimmer es ist schön
zurückzukehren der schulbank und nicht
immer vor dem computer zu sitzen das war
viel stressiger
bis zuletzt wurde landesweit diskutiert
ob das risiko nicht so groß ist bei
durchschnittlich 1400 neuinfektionen pro
tag die zahl ist auch in italien
gestiegen wenn auch weniger stark als in
anderen europäischen ländern
ministerpräsident konnte verteidigt die
entscheidung gestern schule ist das
pulsierende herz unseres landes es ist
ein kostbarer platz der kinder
willkommen heißt und inspiriert sie in
ihrem persönlichen und kulturellen
wachstum begleitet ein nationales
sicherheitskonzept soll die verbreitung
von corona verhindern fiebermessen
masken tragen und abstandhalten im
klassenzimmer soll es mehr einzelne
tische geben
beim möbelhersteller was der radio
arbeiten sie dafür seit august im akkord
10.000 einzelne tische bauen sie und das
ist nur ein teil des gesamtvolumens
insgesamt über zwei millionen tische hat
die italienische regierung landesweit
geordert 2 millionen stück so eine
größenordnung hatten wir in der
geschichte italiens und vielleicht in
ganz europa noch nie und diese riesigen
stückzahlen müssen wir auch noch in
kürzester zeit liefern abstand im
geschlossenen klassenraum
doch ob sich das corona virus weiter
verbreitet hängt auch von der disziplin
der jungen italiener ab auch nach
schulschluss
wenn die usa an der westküste wüten
immer noch verheerende waldbrände
us-präsident jump wird deshalb heute
noch in kalifornien erwartet er will
sich erstmals seit ausbruch der brände
vor ort informieren
betroffen sind neben kalifornien oregon
und der staat washington
mindestens 35 menschen sind durch die
feuer ums leben gekommen dutzende werden
vermisst zehntausende mussten ihre
häuser und wohnungen verlassen
jetzt tennis norbert viertel nach zwei
heute nacht saßen die leute gebannt vor
dem fernseher um alexander zverev und
ihm zuzuschauen echtes hammer finale bei
den us open nach vier stunden und fünf
sätzen sieg der österreicher im tie
break
es wäre verpasst seinen ersten grand
slam sieg und damit den ersten deutschen
einzel erfolg bei einem major turnier
seit boris becker vor 24 jahren
es war das wohl dramatischste finale der
letzten jahre bei den us open in dem
zwei freunde bis an ihre grenzen
gegangen sind und manchmal auch darüber
hinaus als mit tränenerstickter stimme
sich der unterlegene alexander zverev
bei seinen eltern bedanken möchte und
als der neue champion dominic thiem sich
gerne zwei sieger gewünscht hätte liegt
ein finale hinter den beiden dass in
dieser dramatik niemand erwartet hätte
12 gewinnt die beiden ersten sätze und
sie nach einem break im dritten wie der
sichere sieger aus doch das schon
totgeglaubte österreicher lebt länger
und kann die sätze drei und vier für
sich verbuchen
im entscheidenden satz kommt es dann zum
tie-break und als zverev rückhand beim
dritten matchball von team im aus landet
treffen sich allen hygienevorgaben zum
trotz wie sie zwei spieler am netz in
einer berührenden umarmung zu zwei
freunde die der tenniswelt ein
fantastisches finale geschenkt haben ein
spiel der superlative negativer art
dagegen gestern abend in marseille
fußball-meister paris verliert gegen
olympique es hagelt fünf rote karten und
anschließenden rassismus vorwürfe von
psg superstar nehme an die adresse von
gegenspieler alvaro gonzalez
dieses spiel diesen eklat wird auch
schiedsrichter jerome brisa so schnell
nicht vergessen
als der fußball zur nebensache wird
läuft bereits die nachspielzeit ein foul
von benedetto ein paar rhedes ein check
als revanche und fortan gibt es auf
beiden seiten kein halten mehr
insgesamt zwölf mal gelb und fünfmal rot
in diesem skandal spiel kurzawa und am
awi prügeln sich richtiggehend wie zwei
preisboxer gehen die beiden aufeinander
los und am ende fliegt auch niemals vom
platz für diesen schlag auf den
hinterkopf von alvaro monza ist der
spanier soll niemals zuvor rassistisch
beleidigt haben ja sieger übrigens in
diesem denkwürdigen spiel mass c10 am
ende
paris mit dem schlechtesten saisonstart
seit 1985
ja und das spiel willst du wirklich
nicht gesehen werden zum schluss noch
was fürs auge aus dem museum für
naturgeschichte in paris dort werden
jetzt einige der wertvollsten edelsteine
der welt gezeigt manche stücke sind zum
ersten mal in der öffentlichkeit zu
sehen
ein thema dabei der weg vom hohenstein
zum fertigen schmuck wie diese jara leto
grace kelly zur hochzeit ihrer tochter
punkten auch das wetter es bleibt sonnig
und sehr heiß die details hat gleich
gunther tiersch marietta slomka freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind haben wir noch einen
schönen abend danke für ihr interesse
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und da bliebe zuschauer an den nächsten
zwei tagen würde es noch etwas heiser
bei uns diese hitze kommt aus südwesten
und der schwerpunkt liegt morgen über
frankreich mit rund 35 grad aber auch
der blick nach osten zeigte es bis zum
schwarzen meer am mittelmeer ist es
sommerlich heiß mit 30 bis 35 grad und
wir haben im größten teil europa dazu
auch diese große trockenheit aber jetzt
im september kürzlich zeit schon
angenehm ab also morgen früh haben wir
meist 10 bis 17 grad am wärmsten bleibt
es in der lausitz mit 18 oder auch hier
am rhein entlang es gibt kaum wolken in
der nacht und tagsüber haben dann wieder
sonne zu erwarten von den alpen bis zu
den küsten und nur norddeutschland
ziehen hohe schleierwolken durch den
wind spürt man kaum nur östlich der elbe
weser frisch aus süden an der ostsee
direkt aus austin sommerliche wärme auch
an den küsten wieder also 24 bis 26 grad
sonst wird es teilweise heiß mit 27 bis
32 grad und westlich des rheins
vielleicht auch mal 34 oder 35 grad
jetzt wird sich an den sonnenschein erst
mal nichts ändern aber wir bekommen hier
und da ein paar kleinere gewitter an den
alpen und ab donnerstag wird es dann
auch aus osten etwas kühler das heißt
wir haben dann auch in berlin 17 18 grad
aber in freiburg 28 ich wünsche ihnen
einen schönen abend und machen sie es
gut